so jumping into spoiler ending of the
movie uh where did the motivation come
to end the movie with Transformers
finally meeting GI Joe you know we've
talked about it for a long time and the
fans have been you know really rabid
about it which is great you know and so
it makes you want to do it we we never
found a really organic way to do it and
I think one of the things is you just
don't want to do it in a way that feels
I'll say cynical you know that that
you're just jamming in it because
there's more fans and the fans are going
to like it you know so what happened was
Anthony's story the story of Noah is a
character who
is having a hard time because of Life
getting a job and it and it just felt
like so organic that what job is he
gonna finally break through with
GI Joe now I know that it's very early
on you have no idea what the next movie
is going to be but let's hypothetically
talk about it okay you know what I mean
sure so do you envision because there's
a lot of possibilities of what you can
do next yes do you envision that the the
Joes will be a big aspect do you
envision it's a big crossover between
the worlds like how do you see the next
film going I think it'll be hard to do
crossover Between Worlds because then
there's just so much story I have to
tell and I I'm really resisting these
two and a half three hour
giant long overly long in my opinion
um 10-pole movies so we want to tell a
tight story uh I think when you see this
movie there's certain characters look
you got to do Bumblebee and Optimus you
know what I mean so I the way I would
look at it and I think the way we
understand it is the maximals we barely
touched the surface so we really got to
bring them into the story in a way into
the continuation of the story and then
we'll introduce some Joe characters so
it'll be kind of a group if you would
what mission they're going to go on we
don't know what what's what's the task
who are we saving it from we don't know
um but you know we do know one thing is
if you put too many characters in you
don't get to know them
so we're not going to add a host of
maximals or a host of GI Joe's or hosted
Autobots we're going to try to keep the
group somewhat tight so that basically
yeah because I was just going to say
that uh when you have too many
protagonists it becomes everyone only
gets three minutes of story per movie
yeah you know or two minutes even yeah
so do you envision like in terms of Joe
characters like two or three yeah I mean
I we don't know but it certainly
wouldn't be more than that you know
probably more than one and three or less
you know sure I don't know and Stephen
obviously was gonna have a big voice and
what we're gonna choose but I just you
know he and I both share the philosophy
of if we're gonna have some characters
in it
you really need to give them the space
so the audience can relate to them my
last thing on the ending of the movie
ngi Joe obviously there's so many
characters in The Joe Universe do you
have a favorite or two that you are like
oh I have to bring that character in
well it's an interesting thing because
when you think about
do we bring a new Duke in do we bring a
new you know uh it's hard to think about
exactly some of the ones we've done
although they absolutely could exist in
this world so I don't have a favorite
um
trying to think about it do I really
have a favorite my Snake Eyes is
probably my favorite Joe so
um you know already I don't know maybe
Snake Eyes will fit very organically
here I don't know